we're on part b
the region r is rotated about the x-axis
to form a solid find the volume v of the
solid in terms of k so this is our
region r and it's going to be rotated
around the x-axis it's going to be
rotated around the x-axis to form a
solid so that solid is going to look
something like this
it's going to look like this this is
going to be this end of the solid when
it's rotated around
and it's going to look something like
this
let me do my best attempt to draw our
solid and it's going to be
and then that side is going to look
something like that
it's going to look a little bit like a
loudspeaker
and so let me shade it in a little bit
so that's going to be our solid and you
can imagine
you can imagine that maybe this is
this right over here is our y-axis
that is our y-axis and then going
straight through the center of the solid
you have your x-axis and let me just
even if the solid was slightly
transparent you would see the other
side of this opening right over here the
x-axis goes straight through the center
so how do we find the volume of the
solid well we could think about each of
the individual disks of this solid right
over here so think about it this way
let's take a disk right over here let me
take this disk
right over here so as you can imagine
it's a little bit of a cross section
it's a little bit of a cross section of
this solid
so this disc right over here is going to
have some area some surface area and
then it's going to have some depth
i'll do this you can imagine like this
the depth is kind of the edge of the
quarter while the surface area is kind
of the face of the quarter the area of
the face of the quarter so what's going
to be the volume of this white disk
right over here well it's going to be
the surface area it's going to be the
surface area of the disk times the depth
so what is the surface area well surface
area of a circle is pi times the radius
squared it's pi times the radius squared
so it's going to be pi
times and what's this radius
what's this radius well the radius is
the height between the x-axis and the
function so this radius is e to the 2x
power so the area of each of these disks
for at this x right over here for this
value of x is going to be pi times e to
the 2x pi times e to the 2x squared and
then if we want the volume of this
entire disk we then multiply the area
times the depth so times dx so this
would be the volume of this little disc
over here that has a very small
infinitesimally wide depth
what we want to do is sum all of these
disks we want to do we want to have a
bunch of these disks then we want to sum
up all of them so we want to take an
infinite sum of these infinitely thin
disks so essentially we're going to take
the sum of all of these from x is equal
to 0 all the way to x is equal to k
right because this right over here
this is x is equal to k this is x is
equal to 0. we take the sum of all the
disks we will get our actual volume so
we can actually evaluate this integral
analytically it's not too bad because
eta let me rewrite it pi
pi times e to the 2x squared is e
e to the 4x just 2x times 2.
and then if we want to take the integral
you could you might be able to do this
just by inspection but if you want to
say hey look i have a little function
here i want its derivative sitting here
we can what we can do is we can multiply
this expression by 4 and we can also
divide it by 4. if you multiply
something by 4 and divide by 4 you
haven't changed its value you've
multiplied it by 1. but what this does
is it gives us let me rewrite it a
little bit so this is we can rewrite
this as
pi over 4
times 4
e to the 4x i just rewrote this i
multiplied and divided by 4 multiplied
and divided by 4. and the reason why i
did that is so that we have the
derivative of 4x sitting right over here
we have this 4. pi over 4 is a constant
so we can actually take it out of the
integral
and so we can say that this expression
right over here is the same as
is the same thing as this expression
right over here from pi over 4 times the
integral from 0 to k of 4e to the 4x
dx
and so the whole reason why i multiply
and divided by 4 is i have i have
something here i have its derivative so
i can really just pretend like this is
an e to the x
and take its i guess you could say you
take the derivative with respect to or
you take the the integral or the
anti-derivative with respect to 4x
so this the inside is e to the 4x and
you can verify if you take the
derivative of e to the 4x it is the
derivative of 4x which is 4 times e to
the 4x so this
this right here is the antiderivative of
that
and we're going to evaluate it we are
going to evaluate it from 0 to k
and all of this times pi
all of that times pi over four
and so when you evaluate it at k
when you evaluated at k it's e to the
four k so this is going to be pi over
four
times e to the four k
minus e to the 4 times 0 which is e to
the 0 which is minus 1. so this is our
volume pi over 4 times e to the 4k minus
1. and so that is part b
we did that now part c i think we have
time for this the volume v found in part
b changes as k changes if dk the
derivative of k with respect to t is one
third determine the derivative of v with
respect to t when k is equal to one half
so this is straight up from the chain
rule so the chain rule will tell us and
if you view differentials as just very
very small numbers it actually seems
like a little bit of common sense
the rate of change of v so this very
small change in v with respect to a very
small change in t is equal to a very
small change
in v with respect to a very small change
in k
times
times a very small change in k
divided by a very small change in t or
the derivative of v with respect to t is
equal to the derivative of v with
respect to k times the derivative of k
with respect to t and the reason why i
said this makes sense if you view a
differential as a small number is you
would if and and that's not a very
rigorous way of doing it but it's a good
kind of common sense way of just
thinking about things is that these guys
would cancel out if these were numbers
and then you would have dv dt on both
sides so that's why i said that this is
a slightly common sense you can kind of
view it that way but this essentially
gives us everything we need to know we
need to solve for dv dt they already
gave us dk dt at one third at
when k is equal to one half
so they're already telling us they're
already telling us the rate of change of
k with respect to t there we already
know that this thing right over here is
going to be
one third and we can figure out the
derivative of a v with respect to k very
easily because we have v as a function
of k right over here so let's figure
that out
so the derivative
the derivative of v with respect to k
is equal to
pi over 4
pi over 4 times the derivative in here
the derivative of this is just 4 e to
the 4k derivative of negative 1 is just
0. so e
so this is times 4
e
to the 4 k is the derivative these guys
cancel out so it's equal to pi
e
to the 4 k
that's the derivative of v with respect
to k we want to find it when k is equal
to one-half so we could write
v prime
at one-half or when k is equal to
one-half dv dk dv dk is going to be
equal to pi
times e to the 4 times one half which is
e squared so this part right over here
is pi
e squared and so the derivative of v
with respect to t when k is equal to one
half and dv dt
when k is equal to one half and d the
derivative of k with respect to t is one
third it's going to be just pi e squared
times one third so let me just rewrite
it over here so dv
d
dt
is going to be equal to one third times
this or we could write pi
e squared over three and we're done